next i'm going to talk about experience
with
uncle mind myeloid research essay
this is the disclaimer why choose
uncle my myeloid and dssc there are a
couple of reasons
firstly it's the affordable platform
with iron torrent s5 plus and the chef
secondly there are 74 genes with
relevant mutations and
fusions and also another reason is the
small sample size
we can use 10 nanogram of dna and rna
from blood
or bone marrow there is another reason
is the single workflow we process dna
rna sequencing
simultaneously with automation for
library prep
and templating and another reason
is the shorter turnaround time the
workflow is for three days
we basically run three to five times per
week
to meet that turnaround time for
reporting we use
uncle my knowledge based reporter
this is the ngs uncommand ac content
there are 23 genes with hot spots 17
genes
with 4 gene coverage 29
fusion drivers and 5 expression genes
we slice three panels for the testing we
have
aml 56 genes
mpn5 genes heme 74g
the most challenging part is the fleet
three itd
region so this region uh
challenging targets are very well
covered and there is
also a dedicated software to annotate
fleet 3 itd
another challenging targets are well
covered is the cbpa
4 gene coverage you can see it is
pretty well covered those black bars
showed all the coverage
for fusion partners there are many many
known partners
for example for kmt2a there are 199
partners for brav 95 for etv652
abl1 is 5049
and the rara is 45.
what about ngs validation guidelines
so we follow jenny's paper in 2017
for sample requirement and for
validation
so the minimum requirement
is 59 samples
um it's harder to understand the formula
to get a number
but that's what it is required so we
actually did
76 samples for validation
and there is another guideline from cap
required for ngs validation
especially to meet the requirement for
all the molecular pathology checklists
next is the standards and guidelines for
the interpretation and reporting
of sequence variants in cancer
so this is the marine list paper in 2017
it is recommended to include the tier
information into the classification and
reporting
next i'm going to talk about sc
performance characteristics
i'm going to mention about the accuracy
precision analytical sensitivity and
specificity and the limit
of lower limit of detection
this is the accuracy so on the table
on the top of the slide i showed all the
variants
we have validated
among 109 variants there there is only
one of them
did not identified by our essay i'm
going to talk about this in the later
slide
so the accuracy is 99.05
if you look at the lower part of this
figure the x-axis
shows all the variance on the y-axis
is allele frequency the blue bar
shows all allele frequencies from a
different lab we got samples from them
the orange bar shows the results from
our lab
you can see for most of these the
allele frequencies are very concordant
for precision we did two acids one
is the intro and essay the abc
stands for triplicates in the same run
also in the figure you can see on the
x-axis
they are the variance the y-axis are the
allele frequencies abc stands for
different
color of the bars they are very
concordant
the second part for the precision is the
interim essay
the tests were run in day one day two
day three by two
text you can see the results
for day one day to day three the allele
frequencies are very
consistent the limit
of detection we run a sample
include the fleet 3itd
region and we did a serious dilution
from 12 to
0.75 with
expected dna mutation level and the
allele frequency by sql
is on the right side of the slide and
you can see
the allele frequency is very
concordant with expected level
the cutoff is 2.5 for fleet 3 itt
the mutations detect from sera care
reference dna
you can see from the list of the genes
and the variance and also expected the
variant allele frequency
is in the middle of this table and on
the right side
of the table the allele frequency is
obtained from our essay those
expected number are very concordant with
expected
allele frequency the coverage are
pretty high it's usually around two
thousand
the fusions detected from therakia
reference
rna we identified all nine
transcripts from the sample
the read count is above like 10 000
for most of these next
is the data from the fusion we tested
for patient sample
you can see we obtained most of the
sample
identified by rtpcr or
fish or nds from a different lab
that was on the second
column of the table the
fusion detected by sql
is on the third column
we detect all the fusion by ngs except
for one which is highlighted in
red it is pdgfrb
uh identified by pcr from another lab
but not detected by ngs from our lab
so we repeat it like two or three times
then we
finally figured out the primer for the
rdpcr and the primer for the ngs are
different
summary of clinical research data so far
we have run the certain 165 samples
34 percent are from aml patients 10
from mbs patients 3 from mpn
53 from other the abnormality rate
is 56 including mutations and
fusions next
i'm going to show you the molecular
profile for myeloid
malignancies by ngs in terms of the
mutations
on the x-axis these are all the genes
and the y-axis stands for the number of
patients with mutations
so the highlighted area for
the top one mutation is from
type two you can see most of these
mutations are from
mbs patients and also from aml patient
very rarely from the mpm patient
for the jack 2 the next next the arrow
the one
is from mostly from mpn
some of them from aml or mds
for fleet 3 of course it is more from
the aml patient for a tp phase to 3
is about half from aml half from the mds
what about the diffusion profile we have
mostly
cbfb myh11
location next is the run x1 ranks t1
and then bcr able1 kmt2a
rearrangement and the pmrara
for the potential assessment of
prognosis indication
for aml patients in clinical research
study
we know that by cytogenetics there are
three big categories
for risk stratification favorable
intermediate and poor so for co-binding
factor
inverted 16 or the chance location 821
or chance location 1517 they are
favorable
prognosis however if you have a
molecular abnormality with the kid
mutation the prognosis information will
be changed
i'm going to show you some examples in
the next
slide this is the co-binding factor
aml with kit mutation totally we have 34
patient
samples with co-binding
factor cbfb rearrangement 12
samples has remix one ranks t1
translocation six
of the 34 samples
had if you look at this table on the
bottom
cbfb translocations in total
we have 34 patients six of them had a
kit mutation
and four of these are on exon 17.
and for renix t1
running s1 t1 translocations with kit
mutations
there are five page five samples
and all of them are from exon 17.
so if the p if the samples patient has
cbfb myh11 translocation also
a kit mutation on exon 17
it is not really bad if you see the
line the red color and compared to the
wild type
kit mutation it is not
really bad it's considered still good
the next one is the run x1
run x t1 translocation and also
coincides
with kit exon 70 mutation
it will become the poor prognosis
prognostic factor
you can see that red line with kid
exon 17 mutation compared with the blue
line
the kit wide type the survival rate
is worse in summary
ngs has become the standard for
molecular issues
and represents huge potential value to
oncology
clinical research guidelines for
comprehensive biomarker analysis
in hypnologic disorders are available
uncle mind myoloid research essay
provides
a more comprehensive genetic profile
of hematologic malignancies samples
and relevant information uncombined
ngsisa were chosen because of low sample
input
improved turnaround time intelligent ngs
content design single workflow in the
future
ngs results have the potential to change
the paradigm
of cancer therapy and facilitate
precision medicine
with that i thank you for your attention
and i'm ready for the questions